Now, a specific skill that you need to have when you visit any souk...
...in the Middle East, specifically a gold souk, is that of bargaining.
You need to be able to get the best price.
And you're lucky today, because I am an expert bargainer...
...and I'm gonna show you exactly how to do it.
First step: Be sure of what you want.
I want a gold necklace.
Yes, that is the exact one that I want.
Step number two: Don't be so sure that it's what you want.
Yeah, it's okay; I think so.
How much?
10,530.
Okay, how much for this?
1,367 dirhams?
How much is this?
Ah, there, there, here it comes; there it is.
Why do they always use calculators here?
See, she's laughing.
She knows there's something here.
It's not used for calculations.
It's used for negotiation.
Number three: Always laugh at the first price like it's a joke.
That's okay.
Okay, last price: 10,062.
Number four: Never accept the last price.
I will not accept this price.
Number five: Offer your price.
3,000 dirhams, 800, 700 dirhams.
And number six: Threaten to walk away, then you will always get the deal that you want.
If you don't give me for 3,000, I will leave.
3,000; I'm going.